[Musique]
à paris on ne parle donc plus que de lui
le zouave qui a de l'eau jusqu'à la
taille le pic de crue est atteint et
quand on compare avec le niveau normal
et bien on comprend l'ampleur du
phénomène
à 11 heures le dernier relevé indiqué si
m et l'eau devrait encore monter les
quais sont inondées et ceux qui habitent
tout près sont très inquiet caroline
sims jean-marie le quartier paris et ses
monuments les pieds dans l'eau une
barque pour se déplacer l'unique
solution trouvée par ses riverains du
16e arrondissement ce quartier bordant
les quais de seine pas loin de la tour
eiffel est inondée dans cette rue l'eau
est montée très vite comme le montre
cette photo prise hier à la grande
surprise des habitants
j'habite depuis 32 ans le quartier j'ai
jamais vu ça de toute façon un et quand
ce propriétaire ouvre ses volets ce
matin c'est la surprise
il est à peu près 20 cm donc voyez là on
est vraiment à ras et on a des plaques
pour ma peau mais bon elle a cru elle
n'est pas finie loup elle va encore
monter ils disent jusqu'à midi à peu
près donc si c'est jusqu'à midi je pense
qu'on s'en sortira
sinon si ça continue ce soir au ray va
coûter tout est sous l'eau là dans les
caves l'eau pénètre par tous hélas les
infiltrations
je connais un niveau en dessous de
lausanne au sous-sol trois chambres de
bonnes les locataires ont fui impossible
de lutter contre le loup
on a peur quand même on les gens qui
sont en bas la scène charrie des troncs
d'arbres des gravats plus un seul bateau
mouche ne circule depuis quelques jours
les péniches d'habitation sont désertés
pour ceux qui restent le canot est
obligatoire
les touristes et les curieux ce
mastodonte dessus du pont de l'alma le
zouave à de l'eau presque jusqu'à la
ceinture c'est exceptionnel quand même
pour eux même si je suis pas très jeune
c'est quand même exceptionnel et ce qui
est intéressant c'est la vitesse de love
c'est ça qui fait peur parce que plus
qu'à la hauteur avec les quais de seine
inondées c'est le coeur de paris qui est
atteint le niveau du fleuve devrait
encore monter
[Musique]